der premierminister des libanon saad al
hariri hat völlig überraschend anfang
november 2017 in saudi arabien seinen
rücktritt erklärt das sorgte weltweit
für aufsehen und aufregung und man
befürchtete dass dieser kleine aber
wichtige mittelmeerstaat destabilisiert
werden könnte heute in vechta kompakt
libanon inland industries
[Musik]
premierminister hariri begründete seinen
rücktritt mit der angst vor einem
mordversuch schließlich war sein vater
einem solchen zum opfer gefallen
er beschuldigte aber gleichzeitig den
iran in der region und im libanon für
unruhe zu sorgen
und er beschuldigte die hisbollah einen
staat im staate zu bilden
politische reaktionen präsident augen
und ist voller chef nasrallah
beschuldigten unverzüglich saudi arabien
sich hier in libanesische
angelegenheiten einzumischen
die bevölkerung sympathisierte mit dem
premierminister und demonstrierte auch
für ihn über französische initiative und
mit amerikanischer politische
rückendeckung konnte hariri schließlich
am 21.10.11 zurückkehren
in den libanon und erklärte seinen
rücktritt vom rücktritt
warum daher diese aufregung hier ist
festzuhalten dass der libanon aufgrund
seiner gesellschaftlichen und religiösen
zusammensetzung ein fragiles
staatsgebilde darstellt wir haben vier
millionen einwohner auf einem gebiet
ähnlich kärntens 18
religionsgemeinschaften zwei millionen
flüchtlinge und 14 millionen libanesen
leben im ausland und überweisen sehr
viel geld in das land
wir haben ein weltweit einzigartiges
religiöses proporzsystem nachdem alle
wichtigsten positionen und die
parlamentssitze aufgeteilt sind
der präsident ist immer ein christ der
premierminister immer ein sunnit und der
parlamentssprecher entschieden
trotz all dieser probleme ist der
libanon ein ganz ein wichtiger
stabilitätsanker in einer region die von
krisen und konflikten geprägt ist was
wäre im falle einer destabilisierung zu
erwarten innere unruhe und eine
gefährdung der inneren sicherheit
stellen sie sich vor vier millionen
einwohner und zwei millionen flüchtlinge
spannungen sind an der tagesordnung
zulauf zu extremistischen gruppierungen
in europa angst vor einem neuerlichen
flüchtlings antrag aus dieser region
selbstverständlich würden regionale
mächte versuchen in dieses vakuum hinein
zu gehen und ihre position zu stärken
extremistische gruppierungen im lande
könnten wiederum versucht sein hier
einen neuen konflikten
vom zaun zu brechen und nicht zu
vergessen der libanon hat
modellcharakter für die region wo
gezeigt wird dass religionen miteinander
leben können völlig egal welcher
zugehörigkeit und diesen modellcharakter
in dieser region zu verlieren wäre ein
herber verlust für den westen insgesamt
die turbulenten ereignisse haben gezeigt
welch unglaubliche einfluss von kräften
aus der region in den libanon kommt
syrien hat historische ansprüche
allerdings ist es seit 2011 durch den
krieg im inneren mit sich selbst
beschäftigt wesentlich wichtiger der
iran der über den verbündeten hisbollah
hier zunehmend an einfluss gewonnen hat
der auch geschafft hat hier eine
landbrücke aus dem iran heraus über irak
syrien bis ans mittelmeer zu machen mit
hilfe der hisbollah und die hisbollah
andererseits ist ein wichtiger
verbündeter und unterstützt den iran
politisch und zum teil auch militärisch
bei seinem engagement in der region
das birgt wieder das problem dass
probleme aus der region auch in den
libanon zurück gekommen
saudi arabien wiederum unterstützt
sunnitische gruppierungen im libanon es
hat auch beim aufbau der libanesischen
armee ganz massiv geld gegeben
allerdings ist saudi arabien irritiert
weil die rolle der hisbollah der
einfluss der hisbollah in der regierung
im libanon gestiegen ist und auch eine
gewisse annäherung mit dem iran erfolgt
ist allerdings der libanon ist für saudi
arabien unverzichtbar weil es ist das
einzige land in dem es dem iran paroli
bieten kann
der kurzzeitige rücktritt hat gezeigt
dass der libanon zum spielball zwischen
dem iran und saudi arabien geworden ist
die meisten analytiker gehen davon aus
dass riad massiven druck ausgeübt hat
sie gehen aber auch davon aus dass saudi
arabien hier einen erheblichen
imageschaden in der region und im
libanon erlitten hat wie kann es daher
weitergehen für die sechste mai 2018
sind parlamentswahlen angesetzt die
letzten wahl 2009 das neue wahlgesetz
könnte eine deutliche mehrheit für
hizbullah verbündete parteien bringen
auch eine zweidrittelmehrheit im
parlament und damit auch größere
veränderungen der verfassung
insgesamt ist denkbar dass es hier zu
einer raschen einigung kommt das wäre es
ja positiv wo auch die ämter dann
jetzt würden oder zu einem stillstand
das hatten wir schon jahrelang im
libanon wo ihm dann alles blockiert war
und keine entwicklung
die internationale staatengemeinschaft
ist sehr daran interessiert diese wahlen
abzuhalten und hier für den fortschritt
im libanon zu zeigen
[Musik]